et avec nous pour en parler il va en
l'air de l'institut sur la gouvernance
bonjour monsieur alain bourque la
famille audet a refusé cette offre on
l'a vu elle détient 70% des droits de
vote de cogeco avec ce qu'on appelle
vous savez des actions multivotantes
dans le fond c'est la famille qui décide
là pour absolument sûr et je dirais le
l'immense avantage de voir des actions
de contrôle des actions à votes
multiples ce qui effectivement
l'entrepreneur la famille de contrôle
décide si l'entreprise est à vendre à
qui est survendu et à quelles conditions
quand vous aussi l'importance de ces
actions multivotantes c'est
extraordinairement important le je pense
que là les grandes sociétés québécoises
ont adopté ce modèle le plus en plus et
américaines de haute technologie adobe
ce modèle s'est fait grincer les dents
de certains membres du rhdp et aux
financiers mais c'est intérêts de la
société
expliquez-nous brièvement exactement
aussi donc l'importance de ces actions
multivotantes alors c'est une action qui
permet plusieurs droites voit que oui
ceux d'il ya 2 2 classes d'actions et en
classe selon eux plusieurs modèles de
classe car votre réaction est donc la
suivante perfection l'actionnaire de
contrôle eux détiennent seulement
l'antre la totalité ou la quasi totalité
des actions et plusieurs europe donc
quand on met tous les votants ils ont
beaucoup plus que 50% des voix et donc
le contrôle effectif de la société
exactement peuvent conserver contrôlent
maintenant la famille a dit non c'est
une réponse mains sèches
comment on doit être prêté leur décision
mais tu as l'air aux écoutes et je pense
que devant la démarche m'a semblé
surprenante mais quand on sait qu'il ya
une actionnaire de contrôle ces trésors
ont fait une offre
c'était une offre hostile un style et
qu'on allait sa main sur deux est retiré
voilà vous offrant si vous n'acceptez
pas vouloir se battre il offre à tous
les actionnaires ils vont voter ont
possiblement pas c'est de là que tu
noteras quand un actionnaire de contrôle
cette démarche est possible donc
il faut par une actionnaire de contrôle
et voici les vendeurs à quelles
conditions et donc un peu surprenant
couvert s'étoffe et si je réagis
contrôle sinon moi je suis pas vendeur
ouais bon est ce que ça donnera d'autres
discussions mais pour le moment c'est
une démarche qui me surprend donc à
lister ses oies rieuses pourrait revenir
à la charge mais préalablement on devra
parler à la famille santerre d'également
aussi à la famille si on veut vendre et
à quel prix
depuis septembre normal oui oui donc ça
vous étonne qu'on ne l'ait pas fait au
préalable également de tout à fait fait
ça nous ramène aussi cela dit donc à la
problématique qui est de la protection
des fleurons québécois en eux vu
certains sièges sous qui sont disparus
alors on le voit avec les actions multi
matin une certaine protection pour
cogeco mais est-ce que cogeco est un
risque à long terme
bon écoute et éventuellement les les
entreprises les familles qui contrôlent
entreprises dont les décisions à prendre
et at il une succession il ya dessus les
gens vont prendre la relève ou et c est
ce le bon moment devant l'entreprise
mais au moins on le fait nous nous
sommes dans la dans une position de
négociation qui est excellente parce que
voilà nous sommes me ce qui allons
déterminer les conditions acquis qu'on
vend dans quelles conditions c'est de
protéger le plus possible les intérêts
multiples autour de l'entreprise et mais
quand on a pas pris cette décision on
les maîtres à bord et on éviter si vous
voyez vous cette prof s'arrêter comme
dans la situation de renault rno
quelques années on n'aurait ainsi pas
croyable et éventuellement à
l'entreprise pour être vendues quoi
qu'on dise
mais dans ce cas là il n'y a pas de
serre politique parce que les la famille
monsieur odeur de sa famille ont le cour
de rose nette de la situation
est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir cela d'une
surenchère ce club on a parlé qui
pourrait y avoir donc une offre bonifiée
toujours la famille queveau dessiner
mais est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir une
autre entreprise par exemple qui
pourrait faire une offre
on pense tout de suite donc à quebecor
qui a pas de station de radio
ouais enfin on peut toujours spéculer
comme ça un peu probable le trou de il
ya trop de deux marchés où ils sont tous
les deux impliqués je pencherai sur la
concurrence avait beaucoup de problèmes
mais en fait tout est possible tout est
possible mais je pense qu'il faut
discuter avec la colère de goudron ouais
ce qu'est ce que peuvent faire les
balles tout d'abord on ne veut entendre
gouvernement le goût j'en suis le
premier ministre notamment que par le fm
quel genre d'intervention le
gouvernement le gouvernement le goût
pouvait faire pour bloquer la vente de
kojak ou si la famille évidemment décidé
de vendre
bah écoutez je pense que si la famille
décidait de vendre les enjeux son
rapport un acheteur et mensuels son
blues avec le crtc la direction de la
concurrence il pourrait y avoir des
blocages à ce niveau là je pense que
l'on du québec pourrait précipiter
je pense que c'est ce serait se serait
il utile n'a pas initié et au besoin
d'eux et pas besoin de de ce cirque là
on a des gens qui décident de vent qui
vivent c'est pas possible
la société jean coutu était vendu été
vendu des intérêts québécois donc des
personnes qui s'est objecté l'aca est
fort heureusement et tais toi même chose
on sait pas qui mais l'entente votre
téléphone est un homme toujours
récupérer mais sera là cette annonce on
le voit d'ailleurs ça fait bondir le
prix de l'action à l'ouverture des
marchés
on risque d'avoir encore un peu
d'excitation à tour à l'action oui mais
là évidemment l'offre rejetée à moins
que les marchés boursiers ce qui fricote
ya deux ans pense qu'elle verrait y
avoir une autre offre qui va venir le
marché va rester et s'il est là aussi
non si on croit que
la famille au d'être bien clairement
établi que le vent de postes moment six
ans que vous devez voir le tir tu
revenir au haut niveau il était
auparavant il va à la merci beaucoup de
nous avoir permis de voir plus clair
merci beaucoup
bonne soirée et bonsoir